BROADCAST OF INSIDE XBOX.
PLEASE STANDBY FOR LIVE
PLEASE SNDBY FOR LIVE
BROADCAST OF INSIDE XBOX.
PLEASE STANDBY FOR LIVE
PLEASE STANDBY FOR LIVE .-
BROADCAST OF INSIDE XBOX.
PLEASE STANDBY FOR LIVE
HEY EVERYONE.
I'M DRIFING NONSTOP DRINKS OUT
OF THE WORLD'S FASTEST, MOST
POWERFUL FRIDGE.
WE'RE MOMENTS AWAY.
FIRST, I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WONDERING WHAT ARE WE DOING THIS
SUMMER?
WE'RE NOT TAKING THE SUMMER OFF.
WE'RE WORKING HARD.
THE TEAMS CANNOT WAIT TO DELIVER
NEW GAMES, NEW REVEALS, NEW NEWS
FOR YOU.
IT'S TIME TO GET HYPED.
YOU'RE GOING SEE TODAY THE FIRST
AROUND THE WORLD.R PARTNERS FRO-
THEY HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
DEVELOPERS AND CREATIVE TEAMS TO
THE TABLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE JOINED BY
JEFF, KATRERINA AND MALIK.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH XBOX GAMES
STUDIO?
YOU HAVE 15 CREATIVE TEAMS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE MORE.
WITH THAT, I WANT TO WELCOME
MATT TO TELL US A LITTLE MORE.
>> THANK YOU.
AND HI, EVERYBODY.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING OUR
FIRST CONCERN IS, REALLY, WITH
THE SAFETY OF OUR TEAMS AND, OF
COURSE, THEIR FAMILIES.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ALL WORKING
FROM HOME NOW.
WHETHER IT'S IN SWEDEN, THE UK,
DAN, O
DAN -- CANADA, OR THE U.S.
I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH THE
INGENUITY THEY HAVE TO KEEP
PRODUCTION MOVING FORWARD ON THE
GREAT LINE UP OF GAMES.
AND SO WE'RE EXCITED AND WE'LL
BEGIN UNVEILING GAME PLAY FROM
OUR STUDIOS STARTING IN JULY!
INCLUDING SOME FROM OUR NEWER
STUDIOS LIKE DOUBLE FLYING NINJA
THEORY.
>> WHOA!
>> WHOA, MATT.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S TIME TO GET HYPED.
HALO IS COMING.
YOU'VE BEEN WAITING!
THE WORLD'S MOST ANTICIPATED
GAME IS JULY.
MARK YOUR CALENDARS.
XBOX GAME STUDIOS.
WE HAVE TEAMS AROUND THE WORLD
THAT ARE WORKING ON BIG
SURPRISES, BIG REVEALS FOR YOU.
I COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED.
I CAN TELL YOU, WE'RE GOING TO
WORK EVERY WEEK BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN TO DELIVER MORE.
BUT TODAY WE'RE GOING TO PUT THE
SPOTLIGHT ON OUR PARTNERS AND
LET THEM SHINE AND SHOW THEM
WHAT XBOX GAME PLAY LOOKS LIKE.
LET'S HAVE A GO.
♪ ♪
WHAT YOU JUST WITNESSED WAS
BRIGHT MEMORY FROM PLAYISM
CREATED FROM THE GROUND UP BY A
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL AT FYQD STUDIO
IN CHINA.
DEVELOPERS ARE USING THE
HARDWARE TO ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS
AND THEIR NIGHTMARES IN AMAZING
WAYS.
USING THE POWER TO OPTIMIZE THE
GAMES IN THE WAY THEY WANT.
ENSURING THE FANS ONLY HAVE TO
PURCHASE THE GAME ONCE TO ENJOY
IT ON WHENEVER XBOX SYSTEM THEY
OWN OR WILL OWN IN THE FUTURE.
SO OVER THE NEXT 25 MINUTES,
WE'RE GOING TO DAY BEAU JUST A
SLICE OF THE AMAZING NEXT AGAIN
GAMES YOU CAN EXPECT FROM OUR
PARTNERS THIS HOLIDAY AND EARLY
NEXT YEAR.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE ON THE
INTERWEBS, EVERYTHING YOU SEE
HERE WILL HIGHLIGHT THE END GAME
EXPERIENCE.
ACTUAL GAME PLAY CAPTURED 234
ACTION TO GIVE YOU THE BEST
SENSE OF WHAT TO EXPECT WHEN
XBOX SERIES X LAUNCHES LATER
THIS YEAR.
SO SIT BACK, RELAX, AND ENJOY
THE FOLLOWING DREAMS BEING
POWERED BY XBOX!
♪ ♪
TOGETHER WE BUILT ORDER OUT OF
CHAOS.
EACH TRIAL, EACH TRIBULATION, WE
HAVE OUR WORKOUT.
NOW WE LIVE IN AN AGE OF
UNPRECEDENTED BEASTS.
WE HAVE PREVAILED THANKS TO HER.
AND IT IS IN HER HONOR THAT WE
STRIVE.
REJOICE!
THIS ENDS WITH US.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY.
THIS IS PATRICK MAHOMES
QUARTERBACK OF THE KANSAS CITY
CHIEFS.
I HOPE Y'ALL HAVE BEEN STAYING
HOME, STAYING SAFE, AND PLAYING
A TON OF VIDEO GAMES TOGETHER.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF TELLING YOU THIS.
MADDEN 21 IS COMING TO XBOX
SERIES X AND I CAN'T WAIT TO GET
MY HANDS ON IT.
IT'S BEEN A JOURNEY OLDER THAN
ME AND I WAS LUCKY TO BE A PART
OF IT THIS YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHERE YOU'VE
BEEN TO KNOW WHERE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO GO.
THERE'S LOADS OF MADDEN 21 NEWS
COMING SOON AND THE GAME ISN'T
JUST ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN SEE.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN FEEL.
BUT HERE IS THE BEST NEWS, WHEN
YOU BUY MADDEN NFL 21 ON XBOX,
YOU GET IT FREE ON XBOX SERIES
X.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT AND,
HONESTLY, I'M READY TO GET BACK
ON THE FIELD.
ENJOY THE REST OF THE SHOW.
HUGE THANK YOU TO EA FOR GIVING
MY NAME IS SARA AND I LEAD
PARTNERSHIPS FOR XBOX.
I GET TO WORK WITH THE THOUSANDS
OF DEVELOPERS AND CRASH CREATORS
AROUND THE GLOBE CREATING GAMES
WITH MICROSOFT PLATFORMS.
I LOVE MY JOB BECAUSE IT'S ALL
ABOUT CONNECTING CREATORS AND
PUBLISHERS WITH OUR FANS AROUND
SOMETHING THEY LOVE.
GAMES.
BOY, THEY'VE BEEN BUSY.
THEY HAVE BEEN CREATING RIGHT
NOW GAMES THAT WILL DEFINE THE
GENERATION.
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE GOING TO
BLOW YOUR MIND AWAY.
AND I AM THRILLED TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT EVERY MAJOR PUBLISHERS
WORLDWIDE IS DEVELOPING FOR
XBOX.
AND WE HAVE HUNDREDS, HUNDREDS
OF GAMES COMING TO XBOX SERIES X
IN 2021.
THE SUPPORT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS,
GUYS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN PARTNERS AS
EXCITED ABOUT XBOX AND XBOX
SERIES X AS THEY ARE NOW.
WHY DON'T WE TAKE A LOOK AND SEE
MORE OF THE GREAT GAMES THEY
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON.
♪ ♪
>> OH, HARRY.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE?
I'VE TRAVELED SO VERY FAR TO
FIND YOU.
IT'S STRANGE YOUR TRAIL ENDS
HERE.
WHEN YOU LEFT, I WAS -- RIGHT
AWAY.
AND HERE ON THIS EXTRAORDINARY
ISLAND, DARE I SAY I'VE FOUND MY
STRENGTH AGAIN.
I'M SCARED OF WHAT IT MEANS.
I FEEL SOMETHING DEEP WITHIN.
THINGS LONG FORGOTTEN.
WHAT DID YOU FIND HERE, HARRY?
THIS WHAT WAS -- LIKE YOU, MOST
PEOPLE HAVE CONTRACTED THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES AWAY TO GET HERE.
♪ ♪
THIS IS A SUPERDOME.
WE HAVE A CHALLENGE.
DON'T LET IT GO TO WASTE.
TEST YOUR ABILITIES BY GIVING
YOU A SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT.
FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
LET'S GET IT!
♪ ♪
>> HI.
I HOPE YOU ENJOYED THE REVIEW OF
"THE MEDIUM."
THE NEXT PSYCHOLOGICAL HORROR
GAME.
WE'RE EXCITED TO WORK ON THE
COLLABORATION WITH THE LEGENDARY
COMPOSER BEST KNOWN FOR THE
SILENT HILLS SERIES.
WE'LL HAVE MORE TO REVEAL SOON
SO STAY TUNED!
♪ ♪
MY POWER IS PSYCHO --
>> READY?
GO.
♪ ♪
OH.
>> HEY, WHAT'S UP?
[  SPEAKING IN A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE ]
BRIEF PEEK AT SOME OF THE TITLES
WE HAVE LINED UP FOR XBOX SERIES
X.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING!
PERSONALLY, I CAN'T WAIT TO GET
IMMERSED IN THESE AMAZING GAMES.
BUT UNTIL THEN, I'M JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO LIVE OUT THAT FANTASY
VIA CUSTOM BACKGROUNDS IN
MICROSOFT TEAMS.
HOW ABOUT I TRY OUT A FEW NOW.
MAYBE WE'LL GO INTO THE WORLD OF
SCARLET NEXUS OR MAYBE I CAN
TEAR UP THE STREETS IN DIRT 5 OR
HERE IS A QUICK VIEW OF PHIL
SPENCER'S HOME OFFICE.
OH.
WAIT A SECOND.
WE'VE GOT THIS INSIDE LOOK AT
THE NEXUS GAME!
WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO LEAVE
YOU WITH THE GAME PLAY DEBUT
WITH THE HIGHLY ANTICIPATED
"ASSASSIN'S CREED" FOR XBOX
SERIES X.
HUGE THANKS TO OUR PARTNERS FOR
THEIR HARD WORK DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES AND TO YOU AT
HOME FOR JOINING US.
STAY TUNED FOR GO BEHIND THE
SCENES WITH A FEW OF THE
CREATORS BEHIND TODAY'S LINE UPS
TO HEAR MORE ON THEIR THOUGHTS.
WE'LL SEE YOU LATER THIS SUMMER
FOR MORE CONTENT PREMIERS AND
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM XBOX GAME
STUD
STUDIOS AND OUR PARTNERS
WORLDWIDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH!
♪ ♪
>>> SOME TITLES COMMAND THE
RESPECT AND FAN DOM THAT THE
ASSASSINS CREED SERIES HAS
GARNERED.
TODAY WE GET TO TALK ABOUT IT
WITH THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR WHO
IS JOINING US FROM MONTREAL,
CANADA.
INSIDE XBOX.
>> HEY.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
>> I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
I AM A HUGE FAN OF THE SERIES.
AFTER SEEING THE VIDEO WE SAW, I
HAVE HUNDREDS OF QUESTIONS TO
ASK YOU.
BEFORE WE GET INTO IT ITSELF,
DID I SEE NEW ASSASSIN'S CREED
GAME PLAY FOR THE FIRST TIME?
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT WAS DIRECTLY FROM THE GAME
IN ALL THE VIKING AGE GLORY.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
THESE TOOK PLACE IN ANTICITY.
THEY WERE SUN DRENCHED.
MEDITERRANEAN.
AND THIS LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT TIME, DIFFERENT PLACE.
SO WHAT DO YOU HAVE FOR US WITH
THE VIKING AGE?
>> YEAH.
THE VIKING AGE IS NAMED AFTER
ONE OF HISTORY'S MOST KNOWN
WARRIOR CULTURES AND THIS TIME
PERIOD IS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
INVASION OF ENGLAND BY THE VERY
LARGE, HUNGRY, VIKING PORT.
AT THE TIME, ENGLAND WAS A DARK
AGE TANGLE OF BROKEN KINGDOMS.
SO THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTELY BRUTAL
MOMENT IN HISTORY THAT GAVE US
THE BIRTH OF THE ENGLAND WE KNOW
TODAY.
SO PLAYERS CAN EXPECT TO FULLY
LIVE THE VIKING FANTASY IN A
METICULOUSLY CRAFTED JOURNEY IN
AN ASSASSIN'S CREED WORLD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO
THIS.
THERE WAS A LOT TO TAKE IN IN
THAT CLIP WE SAW.
I SAW VIKING LONG SHIPS.
I SAW SOME AXES.
PREVIOUSLY WE SAW A HIDDEN
BLADE.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
KEY NEW FEATURES THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING TO THE TABLE WITH
ASSASSIN'S CREED.
>> YEAH.
SO OUR HERO IS A VIKING RAIDER
WHO IS KNOWN TO LEAVE THE SNOWY
MOUNTAINS OF NORWAY FOR THE LUSH
ROLLING HILLS OF ENGLAND.
PROPELLED BY THE GOAL OF
SETTLING THEIR PEOPLE AND
GROWING AND DRIVING SETTLEMENT.
ENGLAND, AT THIS TIME, IS IS A
HOSTILE PLACE.
TO SUCCEED, THE PLAYERS WILL GO
RATING USING THEIR LONG SHIPS.
THEY'LL ASSAULT FORTIFICATIONS
AND EPIC BATTLES.
THEY'LL HAVE TO GAIN ALLIANCES
WITH KINGS AND LEGENDARY
VIKINGS.
THEY'LL BE PHASED WITH SOME
HARSH CHOICES AS THE LEADER OF A
COMMUNITY.
ALONG WITH THAT, WHERE WE
REINVENTED COMBAT TO BE
VISCERAL, BRUTAL, TONS OF ENEMY
VARIETY.
WIELDING WEAPONS.
WE HAVE A NEW FRESH TAKE ON
PLAYER PROGRESSION, GEAR, AND
WEAPONS SYSTEMS.
WE'RE EFFECTIVELY PUSHING EVERY
SINGLE ENVELOPE TO DELIVER THIS
INCREDIBLE VIKING FANTASY.
>> ALL OF THIS IS MUSIC TO MY
EARS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
XBOX SERIES X.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN EX AGAIN.
IN CREATING A EPIC GAME, HOW DO
YOU TAKE PART IN THIS?
COMMITTED TO NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
IN ORDER TO PUSH THE MOST
IMMERSIVE EXPERIENCES WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
TO HAVE SOMETHIN LIKE
INCREDIBLY FAST LOADING TIMES
MEANS WE CAN REMOVE SOME OF THAT
FRICTION FROM THE IMMERSION.
WE CAN CREATE A GAME THAT IS
MORE IMMERSIVE.
IT'S BREATHTAKING LIVING LURLS.
TO BE ABLE TO PUSH THEM FURTHER
TO THEIR INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL,
THIS IS WONDERFUL FOR US.
IT'S WONDERFUL FOR OUR PLAYERS.
AND ADDITIONALLY I'M VERY HAPPY
TO CONFIRM WE'RE OFFERING SMART
DELIVERY, WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO
PLAY IT ON YOUR XBOX 1 AND XBOX
SERIES X.
I THINK THAT'S GREAT NEWS FOR
THE ASSASSINS FANS.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO ENJOY IT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US AND SHARING THE FIRST DETAILS
ON "ASSASSIN'S CREED"!
I CANNOT WAIT TO SEE MORE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
MY PLEASURE.
♪ ♪
>> WE'VE SEEN SO MANY GREAT
GAMES TODAY FOR KPX BOX SERIES
X.
WE'LL GO TO ROBERT FROM CODE
MASTERS TO TALK DIRT FIVE.
>> YOU SAW THE TRAILER OF DIRT
5.
I WAS LEFT SPEECHLESS.
I MAY HAVE TO GET IT TOGETHER
HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO DIVE DEEPER INTO
EVERYTHING.
WE HAVE THE DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR
IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS NEXT FOR THE
SERIES.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M VERY WELL.
>> GREAT.
GREAT.
EXCITED TO DIVE INTO THIS.
NOW IT OBVIOUSLY IS THE NEWEST
GAME IN THE SERIES.
BACKDROPS ARE IMPORTANT.
WHERE ARE WE GOING TO BE GOING?
>> YEAH.
SO FOR THE TRAILER WE HAVE WHAT
YOU SAW IS GOOD.
>> IT GIVES YOU A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE.
AFTER THEY'RE WE'RE PRICING IT.
SOP THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO
TRACK.
IT'S INTERESTING OFF DIFFERENT
SCREENS.
>> SUPER COOL.
I'M EXCITED.
IT'S A RACING GAME.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CARS WE'RE ABLE TO JUMP INTO.
>> THEY TURN LEFT.
AND IT'S LIKE A DIFFERENT SIZE.
AND IT HAS THE POWER.
AND IT'S BASICALLY DRIFT FORWARD
IT'S SUPER COOL.
MORE, RIGHT?
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE WITH GAMERS WHEN THE
PLAYERS JUMP INTO THE GAME.
WHAT ARE SOME THINGS THAT
FRANCHISE PLAYERS WILL NOTICE
AND WHAT ARE SOME THINGS THEY'RE
GOING NOTICE FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER?
DAY AND HOW QUICKLY THE TIME  O-
CHANGES AND WHAT THE WEATHER IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
YOU CAN PLAY IT WITH YOUR
FRIENDS.
>> THAT'S EXCITING.
IT'S SOMETHING WE ALWAYS WANT TO
SEE BECAUSE IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
YOUR FRIENDS AROUND TO PLAY
GAMES ON THE COUCH.
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
KNOWN FOR THE CAREER MODE AND
TAKING IT TO A BUNCH OF RACES.
THERE AND I HEAR A LITTLE BIRDIE
TOLD ME THERE'S A DYNAMIC DUO IN
THE VOICE OVER BOOTH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT, AS WELL.
>> THERE IS.
THERE IS A DYNAMIC DUO.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS -- IT'LL
HELP GUIDE YOU AND GIVE YOU TIPS
AND TRICKS.
>> GREETINGS FROM THE BATHROOTH
EVERYBODY.
CODE MASTERS ARE A PIVOT TAL
CHARACTER PER USUAL.
ALSO, ARE YOU GOING TO SEE SOME
PRETTY RECOGNIZABLE VASES IN
THIS GAME.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS IT.
>> IT'S SUPER EXCITING BECAUSE
I'M JUMPED TO JUMP IN.
TWO, I FEEL LIKE A LOT OF
PLAYERS ARE GOING TO BE HAPPY
ABOUT HAVING BOTH IN THE SAME
VIDEO GAME.
THAT'S GOING TO BE PRETTY
EXCITING.
NOW, AGAIN, WE'RE HAPPY THAT
IT'S PART OF THE REVEAL THE
FIRST GAME PLAY FOR KPX BOX
SERIES X.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
ARE SPECIFIC TO XBOX SERIES X.
THAT'S WHERE THE ACTION IS AT.
SO AS SOON AS YOU BUY THE GAME
ON KPXBOX 1 YOU CAN GET IT ON XX
SERIES X AS SOON AS YOU GET IT.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY WITH THAT,
YOU CAN PLAY WITH XBOX 1.
LASTLY, IT'S FAST LEARNING.
IT MEANS YOU GET IT TO GO ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUSLY.
YOU'RE IN THERE AND RACING
STRAIGHT AWAY.
>> I LOVE EVERYTHING YOU SAID
THERE.
YOU BUY THE GAME AND GET THE
BEST VERSION FOR THE PLATFORM
YOU OWN.
LOADING TIMES ARE SOMETHING
EVERYONE HATES AND MINIMIZING
THAT.
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
THE FRAMES PER SECOND.
AGAIN, THAT'S COOL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR STOPPING
BY.
I GOT TO SAY I PROBABLY SPEAK
FOR EVERYONE WATCHING WHEN I SAY
THAT WE'RE SUPER EXCITED TO SEE
5 ON XBOX SERIES X COMING UP.
THANK YOU.
>>> WE'VE SEEN SO MANY GAMES SO
FAR BUT THE TRAIN WILL KEEP
ROLLING.
WE TURN IT OVER WITH THE
BLUEBIRD TEAM TO TALK ABOUT
"MEDIUM."
>> GAMES ARE A FAN FAVORITE AND
THE MEDIUM PROMISES TO KEEP US
GUESSING AND OUR HEARTS RACING.
HERE TO TELL US MORE ABOUT THE
GAME IS THE GAME PRODUCER FROM
THE BLUEBIRD TEAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
>> HI, HELLO.
>> CAN YOU TELL US MORE ABOUT
THE GAME AND THE BLUEBIRD'S TEAM
APPROACH TO THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
HORROR GENRE?
>> IT WAS THE MAIN TOPIC WAS
WHAT CAN YOU SACRIFICE FOR
FAMILY?
CAN YOU SACRIFICE YOURSELF?
HOW YOU WANT TO SACRIFICE
YOURSELF TO FULFILL YOURSELF.
AND THE SECOND GAME IS OBSERVER
AND THE MAIN TOPIC WAS IF I'M
STILL HUMAN IF I MIND MAY BE
DIGITALIZED OR WHERE IS THE LINE
LIKE IN THE HORROR STUFF.
IT WAS PTSD.
FOR THE MEDIUM WE HAVE THE 14
HOUR GAME AND IT WAS SPIRITUAL.
WE CAN PLAY AS A MEDIUM.
QUESTION SEE BOTH REALITIES.
AND WHEN YOU PLAY AS A MEDIUM
YOU HAVE PERSPECTIVE TO FIND OUT
WHAT IS INSIDE.
WE HEARD YOU TEAMED UP WITH
LEGENDARY MUSIC COMPOSER.
CAN YOU TALK US MORE ABOUT THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND HOW THAT
INFLUENCED THE GAME.
>> YEAH.
AND KNOST OF OUR TEAM IS THE
BEST HORROR GAME EVER AND IT'S
ONE OF OUR MAIN DIFFERENCES WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT ATMOSPHERE IN THE
MEDIUM.
BECAUSE WE KNOW IN A LONG WAY,
HIS MUSIC IS, YOU KNOW,
DISTURBING, OPPRESSIVE.pAND IN
NOSTALGIC.
WE CREATE IT FOR THE OTHER GAMES
AND IT BROUGHT US TOGETHER TO
FILL OUR TWO ROLES AND OUR
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
IT WAS GREAT FUN.
>> THIS GAME IS REALLY
CHARACTERIZED BY THOSE TWO
WORLDS.
CAN YOU TALK TO US MORE ABOUT
THIS STORY IN THESE TWO WORLDS
AND HOW THE PLAYERS CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT?
>> YEAH.
THE PLAYER IS IS A MEDIUM.
AND SHE CAN COPE.
AND THAT MYSTERY IS THERE.
IT'S LATE '80s.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT CITY FOR
WORLD HISTORY.
OF COURSE, IT'S A CITY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS A DIFFERENT
IN THAT TIME.
BECAUSE IN THE '80s AND BEFORE,
UNDER THE REGIME THERE WAS LIKE
NO FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
AND WHEN YOU PLAY AS A MEDIUM,
YOU HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
EVEN FURTHER.
YOU CAN SEE THE SPIRIT WORLD.
OF YOUR ANGER URGES AND SECRETS
ARE REFLECTED.
SO IT WAS A HOSTILE WORLD, IN
SOME WAY.
SO ONLY MEDIUM CAN SOLVE SOME
MYSTERIES.
AND SURVIVE THAT KIND OF
ENCOUNTER.
>> HORROR IS REALLY A AGAIN ARE
A THAT -- GENRE THAT CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IMMERSIVE GAME
PLAY.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE XBOX SERIES
X FEATURES THEY HAVE HARNESSED
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN
DELIVER THIS EPIC TITLE WITH THE
MEDIUM?
>> YEAH.
OF COURSE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE HORSEPOWER
IS THE HARDWARE.
HAVING THAT POWERFUL STUFF AS A
FOUNDATION FOR OUR GAME IS
AWESOME BECAUSE WE SPENT A LOT
OF YEARS THINKING ABOUT THIS
GAME H WE CAN FULFILL OUR
DREAMS ABOUT IT AND THE
PLATFORM.
THIS IS PERFECT FOR US AND NOW A
LOT OF DOORS WERE OPENED FOR US
TO BE CREATIVE AND GET THE GAME
AS WE WANT IT.
AND THE SECOND MOST IMPORTANT
STUFF IS THE GAME PLAY.
MAKING THE FPS AND THE LOADING
SCREENS.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
IMMERSIVE HORROR AND CINEMATIC
EXPERIENCE.
YOU HAVE TWO WORLDS.
YOU CAN TRAVEL BETWEEN THEM.
STAY TUNED, GUYS.
I THINK I SPEAK FOR THE FANS
WHEN I SAY I'M EXCITED TO PLAY
THE MEDIUM WHEN IT LAUNCHES ON
THE XBOX SERIES X.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE HOW MANY
DEVELOPERS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
AND LEVERAGING THINGS LIKE
DELIVERY.
AN
AND PUTTING OUR FANS FIRST.
WE'RE DOING IT WITH OUR XBOX
STUDIOS TITLES.
WE'RE NOT TAKING THE SUMMER OFF.
TODAY IS THE BEGINNING.
IT'S TIME TO GET HYPED BECAUSE
IN JULY IT'S XBOX GAME STUDIOS
WORLD PREMIERS, REVEALS, LOTS OF
NEWS, AND MORE!
WE'LL SEE YOU THEN!
♪ ♪